what is luminous computing and what is
your great idea
yeah so luminous computing is a
moonshot semiconductor company in the ai
space the
product we're building is the world's
largest supercomputer
and keep in mind right now the world's
largest supercomputer is the size of
you know multiple story building our
chip is this big and it has more compute
uh it's specifically for ai applications
because the number one thing that every
ih
every person in ai will tell you is that
the reason that we're still stuck in
this world where
you know siri doesn't work on your phone
and level five is this thing that's not
going to happen for ten years
level five self driving you refer to
self driving yep self driving with no
steering wheel
self-driving with no steering wheel or
you know the reason why drones aren't
flying everywhere
the reason why you know data scientists
you know their workflow is wake up in
the morning go
you know put a model on aws wait 12
hours and then
come back and see if it's done all of
all of this is the same problem they're
all bottlenecked on not having
just the sheer amount of compute
necessary now that flies in the face of
what
the common technologists would think
we're all sitting here thinking well
amazon created this giant cloud so did
google
facebook also built a huge army of
computers there's supposed to be these
quantum computers coming and nvidia's
making chips
that seem absurdly powerful
unnecessarily powerful
why does any gamer need 4k or 8k
at 60 or 120 frames a second to play
doom essentially it's called fortnite
now
they don't need this much power what are
we getting wrong
why do people think that we've now hit a
level where computing
is unlimited when you're saying it's not
yeah so look i mean i think the easiest
way to see this is to take an example
right so let's take
let's take self-driving cars what does a
self-driving car have to do well
first of all you've got like 30 to 50
sensors on the car so you've got
gigabytes of data coming in
every second then you've got a latency
constraint so
from the moment an object appears in the
field of view of the car so the moment
the car is done reacting
you've got 200 milliseconds to get
everything done
ah you lose half of that time just
because it physically takes time to turn
a steering wheel
so in the remaining 100 milliseconds you
have to take all of those gigabytes of
data
and turn it into a decision in addition
to
this you know the sheer amount of data
and the sheer amount
of you know the short latency you also
have a power budget so for cars
the number is something like 100 watts
and for
right now with the amount of compute
that you need
to put in the back of a car to make a
level five self-driving car with no
steering wheel actually happen
you'd be putting kilowatts of power in
the car and your car will probably burst
into flames from overheating
okay let me summarize yeah because this
is some
a way of thinking about it that i think
is very instructive
solving a bunch of math problems on a
spreadsheet or a database
yeah yeah or ripping uh making a new
pixar film
sure or playing a video game you can
have it draw
in uh the pixar film and render for 30
minutes or three minutes and there's no
big deal you're rendering you can get a
cup of coffee
yeah or it's three or four seconds three
or four seconds
is 30 or 40 times what 100 milliseconds
is
right yeah so the speed at which a
decision has to be made is one factor
yeah the second factor is the number of
sensors we've unleashed on the world
primarily because of the smartphone
which has enabled us to miniaturize
sensors and make them commodities like
so cheap it's ridiculous
so you have people who are engineers
saying you know what instead of putting
three a sensor on each side of the car
and having four they're like well
why don't we just put eight on each side
of the car and have 30
yeah or 40. so now you've got
you know all those sensors you have to
make the decision quickly
and then to process all the data that's
coming into those sensors because those
sensors are becoming higher fidelity
correct
yeah that's the other piece that i think
the sensors are getting better because
they need to get better
right so an example of that might be in
layman's terms the difference between
having a hd 480 when you bought it 10
years ago to 720 to 1080
to 1080p to now what you see 5k
4k 8k screens coming out exactly
so that is literally four times eight
times what we normally thought of as hd
i'm using quotes
some of these other sensors i think are
also getting more precise yes yeah
they're getting
i mean you're putting like eight or ten
light hours on a car
like eight or ten i saw one company do
this
it varies per company um but you have
tons of cameras you have accelerometers
you're you're measuring a bunch of
different type of types of input data
[Music]
and they're all extremely high fidelity
and
you need this this this quantity of data
and this precision you know the
precision in this measurement to
actually be able to ship something
that's safe yeah so then you add to it
the application is critical yeah so we
have
sensors with massive fidelity making
micro
fractions of a section sec second
decisions that are
literally life and death and on top of
that what people
don't take into consideration is when
you put one of those giant nvidia cards
in your tower to play fortnite or one of
these games
call of duty at some incredible frame
rate
it's got four or five fans on it yeah
and a massive power supply
that's plugged into the 110 volt in your
house
now you put it in a car and you have
four of those
which is probably what's necessary right
couple of those in video cards
i've seen eight to ten people are
putting a ridiculous amount of compute
in the back of these cars and
like you said when you put these all
together it it still
barely works and with this power budget
thing
i mean the cars just overheat yeah right
and that's why tesla when they give
their driving range
now when they when you put autopilot on
it's going to draw more power yeah and
when you go to full self driving
their range is going to go from 200 well
i think now their cars are 350.
but a self-driving car might use what an
extra 10 20
of that energy uh i mean for reference
for every 100 watts of power you're
spending on compute you're also spending
like 80 watts of power on cooling uh
this can this can dominate your power
budget
wow for the car this will this can
render cars like not
useful wow so you look at all of this
and you know the way people have
traditionally tried to solve this is by
making better ai or making better
software the
problem is is that the way
naively at least ai has gotten better is
that we've made our models bigger
and so ironically like
the thing that we're doing to get to the
safety is you know
even more utilizing these chips when you
say making the model bigger
you're saying a larger data set larger
data sets more data coming in
no more parameters in the model ah and
so the models are getting bigger
and the hardware isn't keeping up right
so we can't when we optimize to
say use these chips less
we take cuts on accuracy but if we
optimize
the models we take hits on the hardware
utilization